48 hours investigates a shocking crime
inside a Florida millionaire's home su
Rachelle was rushed to a hospital in the
middle of the night in 2018 with severe
stab wounds her husband a wealthy
businessman said it was a home invasion
but when sue woke up from surgery she
told a completely different story Peter
Van Sant reports for this week's 48
hours not a little moment the emergency
know what I mean and believe you
I was called at approximately four
o'clock in the morning on February 3rd
2018 Alachua County sheriff's detective
David Visconti says the call was about a
home invasion the alleged crime happened
at the home of my crew shell a
millionaire businessman and his wife sue
that's Mike on the police dashcam I'm
being advised that the wife has severe
injuries and was currently being trauma
alerted to our area hospital sue had
been stabbed in her neck stomach and
wrists but somehow she survived Susan
had died the truth of what happened that
night would die with her prosecutor
David Byron
when Susan Rachelle comes out of surgery
she tells investigators that there is no
intruder and that the person who
inflicted all of the injuries that she
is suffering from is Michael Rochelle
Mike who had mostly minor injuries was
arrested and charged with attempted
murder the motive
prosecutors say sue told Mike she wanted
a divorce when he was faced with the
prospect that he would have to give her
half of his fortune he made a calculated
and premeditated decision to kill and he
just hopped on top of me and I felt like
this pressure right here and then all of
a sudden I saw a knife come on I said oh
my god why did you stab me and he said
yes but Mike claims sue was the real
aggressor that night I got close to her
right here and
her hand comes out and she was there
anything in her in yeah a knife Mike's
daughter Caroline believes her father
there's no way on God's green earth that
my father would stab anyone Mike and his
defense claimed sue was an abusive wife
who was often in conflict with Mike over
Carolina and Caroline's expensive
wedding only made things worse never in
1 million years what I think that my
wedding would be the catalyst of all of
this Peter Van Zandt joins us with more
on this story Peter it's good to see you
so Mike ensue were both stabbed at night
why were their injuries so different
well shoes were farmed more profound she
ended up in surgery they were considered
life-threatening I've seen the pictures
of each of her wounds appear by the neck
in the stomach and particularly on the
wrist very two deep cuts on the wrist
now Mike says those were self-inflicted
whereas on hit on his side of the ledger
during the course of this struggle he
has superficial cuts he went to the
hospital and went home that night so sue
by far got the worst of this exchange
and I'm curious about the daughter's
wedding Mike's daughter's wedding why
did that create conflict in his marriage
well because the wedding was held at
Oheka castle out on Long Island a
beautiful beautiful place it's like a
French chateau and the talk is is that
her wedding went somewhere between 100
and 150 thousand dollars over budget and
Mike's wife sue who is not Caroline's
mother reportedly was outraged by that
and that created great friction between
Mike and sue I get it that's a big
over-budget and Peter I have to say I
love the shot I don't know if I want to
go in the kitchen to get a glass of
water or go over to the dining-room
table and wait for you to bring me some
bacon eggs and a order of waffles
everything
very nice hey yeah i we have waffles and
I make a mean omelet it'll come on over
don't tempt me be careful what ya house
for Thank You feeder you can see Peters
report Rochelle vs. Rochelle that's
tomorrow at 10:00 9:00 central right
here on CBS